[Music]
on this Thursday night what some doctors
call a triple demek the trio of viruses
and the effect on children the Pediatric
world right now is experiencing what the
Adult World had experience and what's
making the tidal wave of cases worse
defending the north Russia has gone from
a competitor to an outright enemy the
power play heating up in the Arctic a
global news exclusive climate Summit
concerns the flood of oil and gas
lobbyists rattling nerves
and a debilitating brain condition
common in our veterans
I worry most about the soldiers who
think they're okay a Canadian lab's
mission to cure CTE
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us for the better part of two years
Canadians managed to keep cold and flu
season at Bay as pandemic measures kept
people masked and distanced but with
restrictions lifted and social
Gatherings picking up again this winter
promises to be different Canada's top
doctor is warning of a potential triple
threat of illness a collision off
covid-19 influenza and RSV
that's what travares is do come around
every year including influenza and RSV
the pressure on the health system right
now is because these viruses may be
synchronized in terms of the timing so
that's quite different from the last
couple of winters but unlike covid RSV
is surging among kids and half of the
influenza cases in Canada right now
involve children and teens add to that a
shortage of children's over-the-counter
medication like Tylenol Dr Teresa Tam
says pandemic-like protections May once
again be needed in the coming weeks but
some are calling for those measures to
be introduced right now Mike Armstrong
has our top story tonight
you know I didn't I didn't leave the
bedside for two weeks it was Carrie
Graham says the most miserable period of
her life are you feeling better yeah
thankfully it's over Graham's
three-year-old son Tyler was one of a
growing number of cases of respiratory
Sensational virus RSV
[Music]
sharing their story and some painful
videos
she wants parents to know how serious
RSV is and what to look out for if their
trust clavicle area is is breathing if
you can see the breath going through
there or their abdomen that's too much
they shouldn't have to work that hard to
get a breath and and that's definitely
when they need to be seen and so
lethargic that they're not like eating
or drinking obviously you know those are
the symptoms for me that were like
really shocking now one of the problems
Graham hit was a lack of intensive care
beds in her local Pediatric Hospital
Tyler had to be moved by ambulance two
hours away
[Music]
well that's a problem that's spreading
at the Children's Hospital of eastern
Ontario they're already making decisions
they've never had to make before with
their Intensive Care Unit at 280
capacity they've had to open a second
unit to add beds they're postponing some
surgeries and they're sending older
children who need critical care to adult
hospitals
well Children's Hospitals across the
country are seeing a rise in Admissions
and shortages of beds staff and
ventilators the Pediatric world right
now is experiencing what the Adult World
had experience at the peak of covid now
it's not just one illness that's causing
the problem but three at the same time
covid-19 is still around influenza is
growing and RSV is soaring what we're
seeing I think at the moment is a
Confluence of different viruses all
three viruses are usually a problem the
difference this year is when they're
hitting influenza usually peaks in late
December into early January and RSV
usually starts in November instead both
are here early well experts say it's
likely because as life gets back to
normal people are gathering more and
spreading viruses but not only are there
more cases but with RSV they're also
more serious than usual children haven't
built up any immunity it's true
additionally prior to the pandemic about
90 percent of children by the age of two
had seen RSV
now one thing compounding what some are
calling this crisis is the shortage of
medications that would normally be used
to treat children's things like
amoxicillin and Children's Tylenol if
parents can't find them on store shelves
they're more likely to end up going to
hospital that means more admissions when
doctors are dealing with more severe
cases than usual and longer hospital
stays that's leading to a strain on the
system a lock of beds and longer weights
in the emergency room
so Mike what is the government doing
about these shortages well health Canada
said today it's approved a special
importation of two medications it's
bringing in ibuprofen from the U.S
that's already here and being
distributed to Hospitals now and it's
bringing acetaminophen from Australia
that's expected soon there's also been
talk of language on labels being a
problem Health Canada says everything is
in place so that hospitals will have the
labeling information in both official
languages pharah
Mike Armstrong and Ottawa thank you Mike
we've long been told the global climate
crisis is reshaping our planet it's
impacting the way we live and ultimately
how we should better look after it but
there's an extra layer of urgency in
Canada's far north we're melting
glaciers and sea ice are fueling a
different type of challenge maintaining
influence and holding on to a landscape
rich in resources Russia's aggression on
the world stage has renewed concerns
about the state of Canada's Arctic
defenses our Jeff sempel spent time on
board a Canadian Navy Icebreaker and
brings you this exclusive report
Parker Brooke will Transit belt Street
Commander Nicole robichow has served
with the Royal Canadian Navy for two
decades but neither She nor any of her
65 crew members have ever seen anything
like this Margaret Brook Winton poked
our nose into the polar ice cap just
seeing the expanse of the Canadian
Arctic it was quite fantastic
hmcs Margaret Brook is part of a new
Fleet of Canadian icebreakers tasked
with patrolling Canada's Arctic
including the full length of the
Northwest Passage so we went to the
northern tip of admon rings Island
sailing to the edge of the map the
furthest North that any Canadian Patrol
ship has ever dared to venture we know
where the land is by grace of satellite
imagery but what's under the water is
still very mysterious in some places
the melting Arctic Ice is revealing a
vast network of uncharted waters and the
crew finds themselves in a tight spot
low-lying Rock we can see at red one
zero the ship about the size of a
football field is attempting to squeeze
through this narrow passage just one
kilometer wide if the strait had been
somewhere like Vancouver Harbor we would
know exactly how fast the water was
moving and what time and what direction
whereas up here we might not have any
idea if there's a 100 meters or 500
meters or one meter of water you don't
want to Hot Dog your way through a
Transit like that without doing the
research and having as much prior
planning as you can so it's all hands on
deck teams double checking their
trajectory While others scan for
icebergs even for this Arctic vessel ice
that's more than a meter thick could
breach the hull sea ice moves very
rapidly winds and swells and seas really
play a part and where that ice goes and
where we could see it next the Arctic is
warming more than twice as fast as the
global average opening up new shipping
lanes and revealing a treasure Trove of
natural resources and there are fears
that if Canada doesn't assert its
presence and ownership of this region
another country will
Russia has been ramping up its military
presence in the Arctic for years
then in February it invaded Ukraine
Russia has gone from a competitor to an
outright enemy and the idea of an attack
on North America has gone from fantasy
to unlikely but distinctly possible this
Arctic security expert says if Russia
were ever to attack North America the
shortest route would be from the North
Pole
Canada's North warning system a chain of
47 radar sites from Alaska to Greenland
was built back during the Cold War to
detect Soviet bombers
no match for Russia's high-tech arsenal
of Crews and Hypersonic missiles which
makes us very vulnerable because we
really don't have the capabilities to be
able to detect them never mind intercept
them there is a pressing need to
modernize our Continental defenses last
summer Ottawa announced plans to build a
new Arctic surveillance system over the
next 20 years Canada is also purchasing
15 new warships to work in tandem with
its six icebreakers including Margaret
Brook and so whether it's Russia or any
other country they need to know that
this is Canadian territory and their
Armed Forces will enforce that
sovereignty on behalf of Canadians
Margaret Brook isn't built for combat
armed with just a single gun
but the crew believes their presence
alone sends a message we are here to
protect our Northern Waters serving an
important mission to see and be seen
Jeff Semple Global News aboard hmcs
Margaret Brook
as Jeff mentioned the Arctic is warming
at a rate more than twice as fast as the
global average so what's happening in a
hot and Dusty Beach town in Egypt at the
U.N climate Summit matters to Canadians
they're leaders from smaller poorer
Nations have criticized larger wealthy
polluters like the U.S and China and oil
companies for contributing to global
warming and demanding they pay up for
damages there are hundreds of fossil
fuel lobbyists at the summit as well and
as Eric Sorensen reports critics say
they have far too much influence and are
undermining true climate action
great compensation pay compensation it
is the biggest issue for many poorer
countries and climate activists at this
year's Summit in Egypt getting wealthy
Nations to pay for climate damage if you
want one lead us to take this agenda
very serious because our future as young
people is at stake prime minister
Trudeau is not going to cop 27 in order
to attend other International meetings
Canada's environment Minister Stephen
Gibble concedes that this country must
do more that wealthy Nations still
haven't delivered the 100 billion
dollars in climate financing promised
years ago
become more of an issue because we are
now seeing really severe impacts of
global warming the best that
collectively we've done is promised to
deliver by the end of next year the most
visible participants at cop 27 are world
leaders and climate activists but among
the thousands of delegates are more than
600 representatives from oil and gas a
big jump from last year according to
environmental groups and it's evidence
they say that oil and gas lobbyists have
too much influence some are part of
Canada's 300 plus delegation
is an outlier
[Music]
several lobbyists to The Climate
negotiations as part of its official
delegation
I believe this is unacceptable and
sends a message the oil and gas industry
has maintained it must be part of the
solution for example promoting carbon
capture and storage Skeptics say that
still allows for more oil and gas
production building trust is a challenge
it would be easy
policy coming their way tooth and nail
a cop 27 French president Emmanuel
macron bemoan the dependents wealthy
Nations have on fossil fuels but France
and Canada are among the Nations pushing
to overhaul climate financing many
activists say rich country should start
by depending Less on input from the oil
and gas lobbyists taking part in the
summit Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
a rare weather phenomenon in November
coming up the hurricane that hammered
Florida
hundreds of thousands of people in
Florida are without power tonight after
being pummeled by a hurricane in
November tropical storm Nicole slammed
into Florida's East Coast as a category
one hurricane this morning packing a
powerful punch before weakening
torrential rain and Winds of 120
kilometers an hour triggered flash
flooding and cutaway Beach fronts a
state of emergency is being declared
storms this size so late in the year are
extremely rare Nicole is the first
hurricane to hit the U.S in November in
nearly 40 years
while former president Donald Trump is
rotting out the hurricane in Florida a
political storm continues to brew around
him after his biggest midterm election
bets didn't pay out while control of
Congress is still too close to call the
fact that it's even close is being
widely seen as a repudiation of Trump's
Maga message Jackson prosco joins us
from Washington with more Jackson one
will we know which party controls the
house and the Senate
hi pharah depending Which Way Senate
races in Nevada and Arizona go we could
have an answer within the next week or
we could be left waiting for the results
of a special runoff election in Georgia
in December control of the house may
also not be known for several more weeks
because there are still dozens of races
that are too close to call in states
where mail-in votes will take quite some
time to count now even without a final
result here's a sign of how
disappointing all of this is for
Republicans we know that any Republican
majorities will be slim at best and
there's still a scenario albeit slim
where Democrats keep control of both the
Senate and the house something like that
is virtually unprecedented in a midterm
cycle especially when you've got Rising
inflation and an unpopular Democrat
president sitting in the white house
today many Republicans are playing the
blame game and they're looking squarely
at former president Donald Trump who
looms so large in this campaign of
course Trump selected and endorsed many
of those Republican candidates who ended
up losing one sign of how conservatives
may be turning away from Trump is the
front page of the New York Post which
squarely blames the former president and
then there's an editorial in the Wall
Street Journal calling Trump quote the
Republican party's Biggest Loser keep in
mind both papers are part of Rupert
Murdoch's powerful media Empire which
until now has openly backed Trump so
what happens next well both parties will
wait and watch for final results in the
weeks ahead and Republicans will likely
start soul searching they have to decide
if it's time to move forward with or
without Donald Trump
Farah Jackson prosco in Washington thank
you Jackson U.S President Joe Biden and
his Chinese counterpart Xi Jinping will
hold face-to-face talks next week
despite tense relations between both
their countries especially over Taiwan
the pair will talk Monday while
attending the G20 Summit in Bali this is
their first in-person meeting since
Biden became president their agenda is
expected to include trade matters
Russia's invasion of Ukraine concerns
over China's human rights violations and
Taiwan with Biden expected to stand firm
on America's support for the small
country's autonomy
stranded migrants rescued ahead which
European country is taking them in after
days at sea
[Music]
the Ukrainian military is steadily
advancing after Russian troops announced
they're pulling out of the Strategic
city of Curson it's the only major
Ukrainian City that Russian forces had
captured since their Invasion began in
February President Vladimir zielinski
says Ukraine is moving very carefully
since it's unclear how many Russian
forces are still in the region this move
is seen as a major blow to Russia's
military Ambitions because less than two
months ago Russia unilaterally claimed
her son as Russian territory
in Europe France is allowing a ship
carrying hundreds of migrants to dock
after harshly criticizing Italy for
shirking its responsibility the ocean
Viking is operated by a humanitarian
group it has more than 200 migrants
aboard they are set to be welcomed into
several EU countries after making
landfall the ship was one of four
charity rescue boats carrying around a
thousand migrants and refugees all were
stuck in the Mediterranean off Italy for
days because the country refused to take
them in France's interior Minister
slammed Italy's decision calling it
unacceptable behavior and selfish
[Music]
enlisting Veterans for help next The
Cutting Edge Research into troubling
brain disease
physical scars are all too common among
Canadian veterans returning home but now
a group of former athletes soldiers and
researchers is asking for veterans from
any era to help them better understand
the science behind their mental
struggles and what they need is for
veterans to donate their brains Mike
drolet has more on the research to
uncover the secrets of the brain disease
known as CTE
the sounds of war never really leave a
soldier anyone who's been on a
battlefield nose you not only hear
gunfire you feel it too explosions can
rattle even the most experienced
soldiers and leave lasting effects
there's a lot of head contact slash
brain sloshing around in your skull in
all his Years playing in the CFL and
serving in the Canadian military Ryan
Carey escaped direct injury but after he
retired he learned of the dangers of
repetitive concussive blasts and he
struggled to feel like himself you know
I I certainly felt like for years that
nothing was working
um and I felt like I was following
everything and you know the challenge
was just more and more medication and
nothing was working for me what he's
learned since is that he's not alone
he's now running project and list which
encourages veterans to donate their
brains so researchers working away here
in the basement of Toronto's Center for
addiction and mental health can unlock
new secrets of the brain using
radioactive tracers the team is able to
pinpoint and study a broad range of
disorders in the brain everything from
Alzheimer's to autism among others but
their current focus is on CTE chronic
traumatic encephalopathy common in War
veterans and directly linked to
depression and dementia today the only
way to diagnose it is postmortem they
hope tomorrow will be different
absolutely that's our goal we want to be
the first center in the world to image
CTE in life how close are we to being
able to see CTE in live humans I think
we're much closer than we've ever been
these unpublished scans shared first
with global news showed the brains of
two living Canadian soldiers the brain
on the top has had little exposure to
concussive blasts and looks normal but
when they scanned a brain with years of
exposure they were able for the first
time to see a higher concentration of a
protein associated with CTE it's
groundbreaking but not a definitive
diagnosis yet
to get there the team needs more data
more funding and more brain donors
project and list helps donor candidates
register online anything to support
those in need
be most about
um
the soldiers who think they're okay
think they're fine uh but they know deep
down inside that they're walking on thin
ice and any day you know they could fall
through at least now the work is being
done to try and catch them Mike drulay
Global News Toronto
tomorrow in part two of his story Mike
is going to introduce us to another
veteran who's traveling across the
country talking to his peers about the
challenges of CTE and the push for
Ottawa to step up funding for research
that's global national for this Thursday
night I'm Farah Nasser tonight's your
Canada is the national War Memorial in
Ottawa Donna Friesen will anchor our
live coverage of this year's Remembrance
Day ceremony in the Capitol it all
starts tomorrow at 10 30 a.m Eastern 7
30 Pacific right here on global and
globalnews.ca
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
foreign